first class i actually attended was a
class called transformative design at
the d-school i never knew about design
thinking but i heard about lots of good
things about the classes at the d-school
and i decided to check it out and this
class which i chose as my first class
was really aimed at teaching students
design thinking and using it to rethink
their personal relationships and also
rethink their career trajectory they've
also got pop-outs which are kind of
five-week courses that you go out for
instance i did one with the bank of the
west we literally went in san francisco
and brainstormed for them and gave them
some solutions going forward for finance
post-disaster it's been one of my
transformations actually this year and
just way different ways of thinking in
different ways of brainstorming it
managed my expectations about my fear
about not being able to find a job when
i go back to singapore and it helped me
think about more deeply and recognize
that it was due to my lack of
self-confidence
and it gave me lots of tools and
ways to think about how i can pursue
opportunities to address this fear i
also felt like i learned a lot about
design thinking and really enjoyed the
whole design thinking process
and so much so that now i'm pursuing new
opportunities in design thinking as a
next curious step when i go back to
singapore